[Applause]
thank you very much oh i appreciate it
i'm glad you're uh
glad you're in a good mood i got thank
you i got to tell you i had kind of an
up and down week
oh i got all my money finally at a
gamestop
and i uh i put it all into dr seuss
books so i
just up and down
yeah i'm sure you heard about the big
controversy this week yes dr
seuss uh the estate canceled or the six
books were discontinued
for depictions that they said were
hurtful and wrong especially that one
passage
where the grinch says whose will not
replace us
that was
all right
delayed laughter's fun as long as
there's laughter that's i i don't care
how long it takes to get there
i'm just happy for it yeah i can't keep
up with who's on the [ __ ] list anymore
uh you know mr potato head is
i didn't even know what this [ __ ]
thing was
mr potato head is no longer mr potato
head
i'm not sure why but he's just potato
head
i'm not making this i can't i can't keep
up parody cannot keep
up also silly putty is now uh on the
spectrum putty
i it's just it's crazy [ __ ]
but uh you know well here's
among the things i like about joe biden
he doesn't he doesn't buy into this
culture warship
he ignores it and he's got a 60 approval
rating
so you know i think yeah and uh
also levels of malarkey have never been
lower
a good indicator we have but uh no we
are actually as divided as ever
uh 15 states like you started with texas
and mississippi
alabama wyoming iowa no more masks
they're completely opening up again i
tell you half the countries with dr
fauci and half of them are the dr
zeus
and texas they are really radical on
this do not
mess with their guns their god or their
two dollar shooters at applebee's these
[ __ ]
the governor of texas he quoted patrick
henry well not not an exact quote he
said give me liberty and give me death
so he
uh and but president biden he is
he's not he's mad about this he says
opening up too soon we're jumping the
gun
he called this neanderthal thinking and
listen to this
marcia blackburn trump-loving republican
senator from
tennessee defended neanderthals
again i can't keep up with the comment
she did she said neanderthals they're
protectors of family
they're resilient and they're
resourceful and they're extinct
i feel we should enter that into the
record
oh i mean oh it was a sad week for the
trump nuts this week that the q anon
cult
yes yesterday uh march 4th wink wink
was supposed to be the day in queueing
on what nut world when the real
inauguration would take place and trump
would be revealed as the one true
president
just as the ancient prophecy predicted
in the tweet of revelations
who are these people who believe this
[ __ ] we don't know what the proud boys
are proud of but it's not their grades
i don't think these i mean
i try not to be too mean but i mean well
i don't try that hard
but i mean you know they believe in the
democrats running a giant pedophile ring
and that they eat babies and jewish
space lasers and the latest i'm not
making this up
that obama is hitler's grandson
and then you mention covet and they go i
can't believe everything you heard
but if you are any uh cute people out
there you know i am q
uh good news
uh you know if your crest fallen from
this news this week and you need a hug
andrew cuomo is available i just wanna
what are we doing already but because
he's a democrat
excuse me how can a politician of this
high profile
be this [ __ ] stupid we're we're four
years
into the me too era he's this dumb that
you don't get don't hit on the help
don't touch people without their
permission what
thank you one guy
what could this guy be thinking you know
he's hitting on what he said you know i
he told the girl i i'm open to a
relationship with a woman in her 20s
no kidding how big of you
what is this yes
who hasn't dreamed of banging chico marx
some people remember chico marx and
they're laughing their ass off right now
not a not a big contingent but
but no cuomo apparently he asked one of
the the staffers she was 25
how she felt this is you know his her
version but i don't think he's denied
how she felt about having sex with older
men and then he said he was just making
small talk
hey just you know pick a subject any
subject i don't know anything in the
world uh
sex with older men what do you think
start the conversation
he's an amazing man an italian with no
game
and so
so tone deaf you know a lot of people
want him to resign now and he said he is
not going to
leave his job because then where am i
going to meet chicks
tone deaf he said i know people have
disappointed me
but i'm sorry i just won't quit you know
like j-lo's ass
i mean this guy
you